black holes are mysterious and rather
complex space objects
their fascinating parameters have been
flummoxing us for many years
the sheer existence of black holes used
to be just a hypothesis for such a long
while that many scientists didn't used
to believe they were real
even though there is a great number of
these objects pinpointed in the vast
cosmos by now
they still harbor mysteries waiting to
be resolved
and every day brings us a new portion of
data
revealing more of what these stupefying
objects are like
but before that i'd like to remind you
that we're also in telegram
there's a lot of exciting stuff to check
out about space
and our planet like some footage time
lapse films and photos
including the latest ones from the
perseverance probe
the link is in this video's description
and now
back to the story on the 21st of may
2019 scientists were lucky to detect an
incredible phenomenon
a collision of two black holes it wasn't
the first event of this kind detected by
the earth-based telescopes
but it was definitely the first time two
objects this big
were being observed while merging the
event took place less than 7 billion
light years away from the earth
the black hole designation gw190521
was a binary one that is made up of two
components
the mass of one was estimated to be
around 85
solar masses and the mass of the second
about 66
solar masses the merging produced a
massive black hole as heavy as about 142
times our sun
and the stark difference between the
object's masses
triggered a super powerful gravitational
wave
just imagine nine stars like our sun
transformed into energy this disturbance
was registered by the largo observatory
detectors
it had taken the waves 7 billion years
to reach our earth
and it lasted just one tenth of a second
however
this extremely short wave provided no
shortage of valuable information about
the universe around us
[Music]
so what is a black hole in today's
science the term is used to refer to an
area of space-time
whose gravitational pull is so
overwhelmingly powerful
that even light is incapable of breaking
free from there
let alone material objects a
mathematical description of these space
objects is rather complex
the space-time continuum near a black
hole is curved to such a point
that it acquires a set of parameters
completely new to us
black holes used to remain a
mathematical abstraction for a long time
then they got the status of hypothetical
celestial objects
the searching process was not easy as it
is impossible to directly observe an
object that doesn't emit anything at all
including light
the only thing that allows us to guess
the whereabouts of black holes and the
vast expanses of space
are peculiar effects created by their
impressive masses
such as the effects of accretion disks
and gravitational lensing
even though the first models of black
holes were made back in 1784
by the british astronomer and scientist
john mitchell
a celestial object of this kind was
experimentally discovered
only as recently as in the early 1970s
it was an x-ray radiation source in the
cygnus constellation
which is now known as x1 the list of
confirmed black holes today
numbers over a thousand objects and the
10th of april 2019 was the day
when the first photo of a supermassive
black hole
was made available to the general public
thus black holes stopped being purely
hypothetical structures
and were proven to be fully legitimate
space dwellers
just like any other space objects black
holes can be binary
like the one we've seen earlier in the
video in this case
they orbit around a common mass center
gradually building up their spinning
rate and coming closer together
eventually the two objects collide and
merge to form a single object
it is heavier than either of the two
parents as it were
but lighter than the masses of both
original black holes together
the difference in their masses
transforms itself into a gravitational
energy impulse
that disturbs the space around the new
space object
a system made up of two black holes may
also originate as a result of two
galaxies colliding
provided the cores of these are
supermassive black holes
in this case the mass of this binary
system will be enormous
and the amounts of energy released on
collision are really
mind-boggling a good example of such
system
is 3c75 in the middle of the dumbbell
galaxy
ngc 1128-1 the galaxy lies in the abell
400 galaxy cluster
approximately 300 million light years
away from the sun
its peculiar shape is thought to have
formed as a result of two elliptical
galaxies merging
with a massive black hole in the middle
of both
another system of this kind is the
center of the galaxy
ngc 6240 located 400 million light years
away from the sun
it was found to flaunt even three
supermassive black holes
two of them with a mass total of around
a billion solar masses
orbit around a common mass center around
645 light years away from each other
it is notable that the mass of one of
the components is approximately nine
times that of the other
the third black hole lies about three
thousand light years away from the
common mass center
and is as heavy as 240 to 420 million
solar masses this unusual system is the
closest one to our earth among those
made up of three or more
supermassive black one more object of
this variety
is the center of the spiral galaxy ngc
located in the leo constellation it is
about 425 million light years away the
galaxy's center
is a system of two supermassive black
holes that orbit each other at a
distance of 11
000 light years as for other similar
objects
they lie over 500 million light years
away from the solar system it's worth
mentioning that when two black holes get
closer together
they may not end up merging after
spinning and their gravitational dance
it largely depends on the object's
masses their velocities and collision
angle
in certain conditions they may well
drift apart
never to come closer again and the only
result of their interaction
may be seen in altered trajectories
the process of merging black holes wants
much deeper studying at this point
there are a lot of blank spots on the
mathematical description
it is a really complex mathematical
model that may take
years and years to work out observation
of real mergers meanwhile
is certainly greatly beneficial for
scientific pursuits
in this field the thing that is crystal
clear now
is that a staggering amount of energy is
released during the process
tantamount to billions of supernovae it
is mainly released in gravitational
waves
all of these registered by now have
traveled to the earth for billions of
years
which means that their energy has
largely dispersed
on the way what would happen to our
planet
if there was the source of a similar
wave close by
say right in our galaxy
according to some estimates when black
holes merge
the gas in the accretion disks is heated
up and accelerates to reach
extra high speeds this causes emissions
of electromagnetic waves
predominantly in the ultraviolet and
x-ray bands
if their source were to find itself
close enough to our earth by space
standards
the magnetosphere and the ozone layer of
the planet would not be able to stand
such a powerful assault of radiation
in this scenario all life on the surface
would almost
certainly be doomed some organisms might
have a chance to survive in the depths
of the earth's interior and oceans
but most of the biosphere would be
likely to be eliminated
in addition to that if this wave was
strong enough
it might cause perturbations on the
planet's mantle
which in its turn would lead to multiple
ruptures in the crust
massive earthquakes and volcano
eruptions
what about the black hole itself looking
at its evolution after the merger
its shape is estimated to remain either
irregular or elongated for a while
the black hole will pulsate and
gradually the amplitude of the
fluctuations will diminish
with the object eventually assuming a
regular shape
by forming an accretion disk it will
continue to attract matter all around it
and suck it in there are more collisions
and merges to come for the newly formed
black hole
but in the end all matter around it will
be absorbed
and the growth of the black hole will
first slow down
and then cease completely with nothing
else to feed on
as proven by the outstanding american
physicist stephen hawking
along with two other prominent
scientists starabinsky and zeldovich
from the ussr
any black hole constantly emits
particles
and slowly but surely loses its mass
this phenomenon is referred to as the
hawking radiation
it is on account of this radiation that
the temperature of any black hole will
depend on its mass
the lower the temperature the heavier
the hole
for example one whose mass is six times
that of the sun
will have a temperature in the region of
10 to the power of minus
8 kelvin which is close to absolute zero
this means that the heavier a black hole
the slower it takes it to evaporate
the life expectancy of supermassive
black holes is estimated to be over
10 to the power of 100 years the number
also known as google while the
temperature of a black hole is lower
than that of the cosmic microwave
background of the universe
that is 2.7 kelvin its mass cannot
diminish
but the universe keeps expanding and the
cmb temperature gradually decreases
even though it is an extremely slow
process
that is why sooner or later any black
hole is to get in the state of
thermodynamic equilibrium
when the amount of energy evaporated
equals the amount of energy absorbed
lighter objects will reach this state
sooner than heavier ones
after that the black hole will start
losing its mass at an ever-increasing
rate
even though it will take trillions of
years for the process of complete
evaporation to run its course
eventually it will culminate in an
enormous burst
the black hole will vanish leaving
behind a staggeringly powerful
electromagnetic impulse that will
gradually disperse
in the expanses of the universe the
demise of the last black hole in the
universe
will herald the beginning of the dark
era
the age of infinite emptiness and cold
the real ultimate fate of the universe
dear friends we put in a lot of effort
to make our videos informative and
interesting to watch it really means a
lot to us when you hit the like button
this way you support our channel and if
you hit the bell button you will always
be in the loop
and never miss new videos about all
sorts of exciting things out there
and in the meantime we'll be preparing
something new for you
let's keep in touch
[Music]
you